hello welcome to the daily homeroom sal
khan here from khan academy for those of
you for those of you uh that this is the
first time you're joining this is
something that we're doing on a daily
basis so that we all feel connected in
this time of school closures and social
distancing it's a time for you whether
you're a student a parent a teacher to
ask questions so whatever social media
platform you're watching this on
start asking questions on the messages
below we have team members who are
surfacing some of those questions up to
me and our guests so that we can answer
them for you we want this to be as
interactive as possible the reason why
we think it's important to have this
connection is you know we have all these
materials on khan academy to support you
in your various academic subjects we
publish things like the daily schedules
to structure your days in different ways
all of this is available for free at
khanacademy.org
we've been doing parent and teacher
webinars as well
but then to support that on top of that
and i do want to remind everyone we are
a not-for-profit organization with a
mission of free world-class education
for anyone anywhere and so if you're in
a position to do so please think about
donating to khan academy we were already
running at a deficit before
the covid crisis and uh ever since the
school's closed our traffic is up over
two two and a half times what it
normally would be i do want to give a
special thanks to several corporate
partners who have stepped up in record
time to make sure that we can
keep running although we continue to run
at a deficit
bank of america 18t google.org and of
artists if any of you potential
corporate partners are out there
listening please think about helping us
do this because we still need more help
from corporate partners from individual
gifts even if you can donate three
dollars five dollars ten dollars it all
makes a difference so today we have a
very exciting guest we uh yesterday we
talked about mental health and today
we're going to talk a little bit about
physical health and i think we all have
a sense you know we have those daily
schedules where we said hey this is
where you can work on math on khan
academy this we could work on english
and language arts but we had breaks in
there and we kind of threw in hey you
could do yoga now or you could go for a
run but today we have an expert michelle
carter from shape america so michelle
before the covet crisis what were you
doing or what are you doing
well that's a great question i think
we've all been kind of uh sidetracked
with this covid 19. but shape america is
a
shape america is a non-profit um
association for health and pe teachers
we serve as the voice of kids
let me check with felipe
are you all hearing michelle because i
can't hear
is it only me
oh okay so
here's her so maybe something's wrong
with my
michelle keep talking
okay i'm here i just
like can you hear me now
hear you
can you hear me now
okay
so um as i was saying the shape america
serves as the voice of over 200 000
health and pe teachers and so we're
dedicated to helping health education
teachers and physical education teachers
with what they need to teach students
how to live
their best life physically and
emotionally so i'm a former health and
pe teacher and so i
really serve as a subject matter and
content expert for shape america
okay so um
one of the things that's really
important when you are thinking about
creating physical activity experiences
for your children
are that
you want to accumulate about 60 minutes
of daily physical activity for
school-aged children around ages 6 to 17
years old and this is recommendations
that come from cdc and for
preschool-aged children um thinking
about three to five years old there
isn't a set time but um just making sure
that there's getting physical activity
throughout the day so some specific
examples of the kinds of things that you
can do with your younger children
are using things around your house it
doesn't have to be elaborate doesn't
have to um even take a lot of time as
long as you're just providing that
opportunity for your children to move
and one example is using things like
paper plates or if you have pillows or
even
a hand towel something flat and you can
spread that around um an area and having
jump from rock to rock and so this works
on the skills of balance and locomotor
and leaping and then if you're able to
go outside you could use sidewalk chalk
and and draw circles and have them
leaping um really at the early childhood
age around three to five
uh imaginative movement is really good
for for young children um having to move
their bodies in different ways so asking
them can you make your body like a
circle can you make your body like a
triangle or the letter s and so getting
them to be creative while they're moving
their body and exploring how their body
moves in different ways
i know we probably the go-to exercise of
movement is walking
and it's really good even for little
ones but specifically for little ones
having them practice those
locomotor movements again as well as
galloping and skipping and hopping they
can do that along the sidewalk um so
just thinking about ways that they can
move while walking
um in your house or even outside you can
ask them touch three things that are
green touch one thing that is red so
just having them
you're working on colors and then
following directions and they're moving
at the same time so very simple things
and then of course one that is
easy to do is with music and using music
as a great tool so playing different
types of music with fast tempos or
slower tempos and asking them well how
can you move your body to the the beat
of this song so if they're moving fast
they can get kind of upbeat or if
they're slow
and they move their bodies slow um
classical music is a great opportunity
to use because the the variations in the
tempo or if there's loud drums or
clashing symbols
um and so we have a lot of resources at
shapeamerica.org
especially on our early childhood
calendars are really great we have tons
of resources there with plethora of
ideas for our little our young friends
our young children
um
so specifically going back to
school-aged children that's that's
categorized as six to 17 year old
children and so really making sure they
get an hour of moderate to vigorous
physical activity throughout the day so
that means their heart rate is up
they're breathing harder and if they did
it long enough they
get sweaty
hi hi
so i apologize everyone we have a little
bit of technical difficulties so i'll be
stepping in until sal gets set up uh
with questions from no problem yeah so i
think we have a couple of good questions
that are already coming in all right
we have a really good question from
facebook michelle it's from scott yang
and the question is michelle what do you
what if you live in a tiny home how do
you exercise inside a tiny space
absolutely so um you don't need a lot of
space necessarily but this is where
creativity comes in really great so one
thing that
using the things that you already have
in your house so one example is if you
have candy land or another card game or
monopoly or something like that you can
use the cards from that game and assign
exercises to the colors or the suits or
the character
and then so for example in candyland if
you draw a blue color you can do um
running in place for 20 seconds or
something like that and one thing you'll
hear me talk about a lot um
through this is allowing your children
to have choice that's really important
so ask them what do you want to what
should we do if we pick blue what should
we do if we pick red so getting them
involved and i'm coming up with the
rules of the game
hi sal hey michelle i can finally hear
you so
apologies good
but but uh felipe did some heroic back
end rewiring of everything it looks like
we're all good and thanks dan for being
able to step in and dan's always in the
background helping us so i should always
be thanking him uh and i i it sounds
like y'all already got started and i i
think i got a sense of of of where y'all
are
i guess maybe one way to think about it
is what is and maybe you just said this
so i'm i'm i'm late to this party what a
target amount of physical activity that
you would like children to be getting
maybe of different ages
yes so um
for that school age group um six to 17
years old they're about an hour of 60
minutes of physical activity and so
we're saying moderate to vigorous um so
they're breathing harder heart rate is
up and if they were to do this activity
long enough you know they'd start
working up a sweat for younger children
that's preschool age there isn't
necessarily a set time but just
providing opportunities for physical
activity and movement and
imaginative movement throughout the day
so that they can explore how their body
moves
yeah and for those younger crowd it's
almost hard to stop them from moving
yeah
i once for kicks put a step tracker on
my five-year-old and saw what happened
and he has a lot of stuff to this day
but but that's interesting
is kind of more a little more rigorous
a walk is nice but uh if you can maybe
work up a sweat dancing yoga
running
some type of you know shooting hoops you
know socially distance just with your
family i guess
stuff like that so walking walking is a
great is a great exercise and you can
make walking um more intense too by
speeding up um your pace or looking to
go up hills
even adding in skipping
um and things like that to make it a
little bit more challenging so walking
is i know it's kind of a go-to thing
because it's easy to do and it is very
effective so walking is great um you can
even throw in other things with other
movements like lunges or squats and
things like that just to ramp it up a
little bit
too
and what do you think about pacing is it
uh an hour all at once or do you imagine
it being three 20 minute sessions over
the course of the day
so i think breaking it up is the best we
kind of don't want to just get our bout
of physical activity in one
time and then be sedentary the rest of
the day so one of our recommendations is
two is getting um
using creating a recess time i know you
all have been talking a lot and we've
all been talking about the importance of
creating these routines so again
creating this routine of if you know you
have lunch around 12 or 12 30 schedule
in that that 20 to 30 minutes of
dedicated physical activity time before
lunch and that's really beneficial
because what it does too was before
lunch it
they're getting that energy out they
come and they're ready to eat they're
going to be more likely to eat those
vegetables and those fruits those
healthy foods that you're putting in
front of them and um it also serves as
like a cool down period um
so that after lunch if you're ready to
get back into the learning aspect into
academics they're settled and they're
focused and ready to learn
that's super helpful and and my sense of
it is not only is it important for the
physical activity component but that
blood flowing throughout the whole body
is actually useful for the learning
itself so that's why it's good to go
absolutely back and forth so we're
getting a ton of questions on social
media go
no no i'm ready for questions
okay
okay so let's see there's a couple of
from youtube ashutosh asks hi sal how
can someone keep a teen doing physical
activities who cannot go outside because
of living in a congested urban area and
they like coding i don't know if those
are the same
but someone who lives in a yeah you live
in new york in a you know dense
environment might not be a green space
outside
green space or maybe safety issues or
something just not access definitely
that's a great question
so one one thing that
is very important and this opportunity
that comes with this crisis is that
allowing students to take ownership of
their health and allowing them for
choice so if they can
create their own schedules and decide
how they want to move and allow some
creativity i think that's really
important for them to do
to choose things that are
exciting for them and that they like to
do um to create
their own movement and so we have a few
resources um especially within our take
home packet that
kind of guides them through that so like
with a physical activity log um some
guidance on how to create some of these
things we have these movement calendars
like our mind and body calendar that
they can follow along with
um and different types of exercises like
that
online too if they're into coding and i
know we always stress about you know
screen time but if they're using the
screen time to
find different types of
ways to be active i know there's lots of
websites
i'll just fitness blender is one where
they can create their own they can kind
of tailor it to what they want to do so
creating goals and so we can get into
goal setting with that
um and allowing them to take ownership
because we really want to set the stage
for them to be able to keep this as
they're they're entering into adulthood
and see the value in it
awesome a lot more questions this one
from xiao luo and facebook uh this is
just interesting my daughter is asking
if a thousand jump ropes is enough
exercise for a day for a 14 year old
that sounds pretty intense
that does sound pretty intense and a
very specific so i think it would be
more about um
the time spent
if it took you
30 minutes to do a thousand jump ropes
you'd want to look at okay that's i got
half of my activity in and so what are
other ways can i get movement in um it's
good for all of us you know a children
especially to you know try not to be
sitting for too long in one sitting so
that's really good a thousand jump ropes
but if you could also find other
opportunities to get up and even just
for a few minutes i mean um
take a quick
break if you have stairs in your house
or in your apartment building you know
walking up and down the stairs for a
couple of minutes um challenge yourself
in those ways
those are great ways to to continue to
add to that minutes you really want to
get those 60 minutes if you can in a day
yeah no but it sounds like shao you have
a
a pretty hardcore a daughter but yeah
she could keep going you know yeah yeah
just keep going
a thousand a thousand is really good
that's good i've tried i used to be into
jump rope it might not be physically
obvious
but
a thousand yeah i mean because if you're
doing it fast with the fast rope you can
you're going about two per second so
yeah it's about you know right about
five ten minutes but it's a good example
of if you have a jump rope at home
you can use the jump rope to get your
heart rate up and it doesn't take a lot
of space you could also
use it to help stretch or use it to
create balancing and different exercises
with a jump rope too so
yeah so the other question so this is an
interesting i think a lot of people
having this question generally this is
from sohom sanu on facebook is running
walking on trails outside safe during
the coronavirus
so from my understanding of what i've
read on the cdc guidelines it is safe to
be outside um as long as you're
not coming into that within that six
feet of
someone else so it's still okay to take
your children outside um you just don't
you know it's not as safe to have them
playing with other children or that
close contact but certainly go outside
with them um
we did a chalk your walk challenge on
social media that was really fun so
letting them still get outside and
thinking about those ways that they can
move i mean even if it's in your
driveway or if there's a sidewalk um
draw big squiggle lines on the the floor
and have them try balancing and moving
in those pathways use the music as a
really good opportunity if you can play
music and have them move to the music
another thing is that
we're as adults we're a little bit
further removed from physical education
class so ask them um what do you do in
class and what are some things that you
think you can teach us to do that you've
learned in your your health and pe
classes to get us moving um and kids are
so creative that they'll come up with
that but i encourage people if they can
you know take them outside
and still use those trails
just be mindful about how much they're
being used and then also follow your
state
um
if you have a stay-at-home order and
making sure you look into if if you can
go outside and use those public
facilities
yeah i know personally you know if not
for outside i think a lot of us would
find this even that much more difficult
you know in my neighborhood i'm seeing a
lot of people going for walks and runs
we have a nice park locally we have some
trails not too far away and it's really
just about keeping that that distance uh
you know it's almost funny in our
neighborhood you can walk and people
just part you know far more than six
feet uh but i think that's it's always
it's always good to be prudent so let's
see this is i guess it's more of a khan
academy question although maybe we might
work together on this michelle from
camilla on youtube any plans of having
pe health on khan academy
uh i felt like people in school
lacking only ever played football so i'm
learning how to be active and healthy in
ways i enjoy you know i i i that's
definitely an interesting idea but in
the in the in the meantime there's a lot
of stuff obviously on the internet on
youtube on shape america's website uh
you know i in our schedules i put some
of my favorite activities that you can
find on youtube like some of these
dancing things where you have to you
know just dance or dance dance
revolution
that type of stuff yoga there's a lot of
i mean there's unlimited stuff on
youtube you could find but it is
interesting if we did something as well
right and so i do want to make a
distinction that was a great question
camilla for a little plug here for shape
america is just that distinguishing
between physical activity and physical
education so physical activity is just
movement and any kind of movement where
you're expending energy
but physical education is really
important and especially health
education and i think
we can really see it in this moment is
that where there's standards and
objectives that go along with actual
learning and physical education so um
i've heard a lot of stories of i'll give
you example of um people who were
athletes in school and their coaches
were telling them what to do but as soon
as they lost that coach they were no
longer involved in that sport they no
longer they found themselves they didn't
know how
to actually take that what i keep
talking about that ownership of how to
take care of their health and their
their wellness and so with health and
physical education it's teaching them
those skills so that when they do are an
adult um they know how to be physically
active they have the skills so that they
can be physically active for a lifetime
they do have the skills to take care of
their mental and emotional health as
well
and so we see it's very important right
now because
we're at home and so we're finding
challenges of being physically active
we're also finding challenges of taking
care of our our emotional and our mental
well-being as well
so um if you ever change your mind sal
shape america is here to help you with
that
no we might be providing resources
around that
and that's a really good distinction you
made which is it's not i mean the
physical activity is important
especially in in this time but it's that
plus the knowledge the frameworks the
self-agency uh that you can be that can
be taught in a traditional physical
education or health class absolutely
absolutely
so let's see someone from youtube
uh actually this isn't facebook kim
randall asks can your ability to run
while keeping oxygenated be compromised
by wearing a mask as the current
guideline suggests i guess in some
places they are recommending wearing
wearing a mask right
well
i'm not sure you would probably want to
consult with a doctor because yes i you
know wearing a mask can impede your
breathing and it could make um labor
your breathing so i would probably um
err on the side of caution with using a
mask
while doing something that's very
strenuous and you're taking a lot of
your breathing in
you're breathing harder and you need
more oxygen um so walking with a mask is
absolutely fine but if you're doing
something like high intensity interval
training um you might want to
do that somewhere where you don't need
to do wear a mask
yeah i remember when they're there they
had the fires here in california and the
air quality wasn't so great i was
wearing one of those n95s and yeah it is
very hard to run with an n95 mask on yes
definitely you don't get a lot of air
through so this is an interesting
question it's both academic and from a
physical education point of view it's
from youtube sure um
my non-traditional life that's the
username any advice for kids who are
resisting following a schedule doing any
school work or exercise i don't want to
push too hard during this traumatic time
but my sibling has been resistant
so how do you convince that is a
that's a great question um so i kind of
thought about that a little bit um
i think really when you
think about ways where what's engaging
to that person what is that person like
this is a strategy in teaching as well
too is like getting that person to um
choose and identify the things that they
like and how can they use that to
incorporate into physical activity and
really identifying what some of the
immediate benefits are with that what
what's the benefit of being physically
active so if they're complaining about
you know i'm not sleeping well well
physical activity is a great way to
promote sleep um figure out some of
those things of what they're going
through i'm feeling lonely or
i'm just kind of down in the dumps about
not being in school and so those kinds
of things physical activity um is a
great way to kind of lift moods and
spirits um and talking about that and
that really i mean part of if it's
another uh
a teenager or something you know a young
person who isn't an adult it's like well
we can't get too out of that routine i
mean we're going to have to go back to
it eventually we're taking a you know a
big pause in our life but we want to
stick with
um
sticking with the schedule it'll make us
feel better physically it's going to
make us feel better
emotionally that's great advice and what
i'm finding you know why my younger my
youngest who's five years old oftentimes
if you ask to do something directly he
automatically resists like take a bath
he's like no you know let's go for a
walk he'll say no but if you do a little
bit of a deflection maybe stroke his ego
a little bit say hey that was really
amazing how you got that stuff done hey
can we talk about it now i'm just going
to be outside and as soon as they're
outside then
then all sorts of good stuff yes yes
that's true and yesterday i remember
even talking about that praise to point
out the great things that that person
has those strengths and stuff like that
so yes that's a great tip
yeah i hate to admit it but i think it
works with me as well but
it does i we had a running joke in my
family where you know if i wanted to get
my younger siblings to do something all
i had to do was say i'll time you
so
my oldest is like that you ty you
measure it he wants to do it uh
let's see challenge
it's a facebook lillian carrera senko
asks what are your feelings about
preschoolers incorporating yoga into
their physical activity for the day
um i think it can be done well it's a
good
it's a good strategy of like stretching
and kind of using what i mentioned
earlier is about that imaginative
movement so um if you're talking about
different things like cobra pose and
talking about let's we can be like
cobras and snakes and getting into that
position
that way and kind of just picking ones
that are are fun for them to do
child's pose i think it's a nice way to
get them to move and then again
asking them well what are some different
ways we can stretch our bodies together
and so allowing them to really explore
um so with the little ones like
preschool age it's about them being able
to
explore the body movement how their body
moves in those kinds of ways so yoga is
a great way to kind of lead them into
that and then asking them what other
animals in nature can we move with
that's great and you know yoga itself my
understanding is it was first developed
thousands of years ago in india as a way
of preparing the body for meditation
so there's an interesting aspect of it
so it's great to intersperse and
especially in this time where uh people
are just trying to get into a better
mental place as well and not get too
anxious
that yoga not only is a physical but it
can relax you and then i get you focused
for other things
let's see so other
there's a lot of questions of here uh
for sophie foster on youtube asks what
kind of foods would you eat to get more
energized
after doing more per i guess in general
more energized
um that's a great a great question so
carbohydrates are usually foods that
fuel you they are our body's number one
source of energy um so it kind of
depends on what you're trying to do if
you know you're going to do something
with um
an extended period of time so you know
you're going to go for a more intense
longer um you think about eating
carbs complex carbs more in the
beginning of the day but really you know
bananas and fruits those are really good
healthy carbohydrates for you to eat
that provide energy eating um you can
eat a banana after a workout or even
before a workout
so you know really fruits and vegetables
are great ways to to
get that energy in
um
and so you'll find too as you become
more active it increases your metabolism
and so you might become more hungry
and so um just making sure you're eating
those healthy
those healthy foods um to fuel you
yeah and our brains use a large portion
of our calories too that's why yeah
there's a lot of energy there people
don't realize it and the other good
thing about fruits is the vitamin c
which obviously is valuable for fending
off your horses
absolutely so let's see there's
there's kim randall from facebook asks
what should we do instead if we can't
run should we walk fast yeah sometimes
my knee gives me troubles you know there
might be other reasons why someone can't
run what do you recommend
yeah i think i
to me walking is such a great it's very
effective everybody can do it um it's
also if you plan it throughout your day
it could be a great time to bond with
family and there's a lot of different
things you can do to kind of make it a
little more interesting um speaking
again towards the younger children
name 10 things that start with the
letter of your name that we see on our
walk
maybe you do one day a noticing walk
where you're
looking around for things you've never
noticed
before that maybe you've never paid
attention and it kind of goes into that
mindfulness piece where you're
practicing being in the moment and
you're not thinking about what's going
to happen or what has already happened
and then you can add the challenge of
let's not talk and then at the end of
our walk we can kind of like did you
notice this and kind of compare um one
that i thought was good was the social
distancing walks
um so
can if you're friends with your neighbor
you know hey let's take a walk you're on
that side of the on the other side walk
we're on this one and then we can shadow
each other so taking turns kind of like
a follow the leader type of game
um and then yeah changing the speed and
tempo of your walk those are simple ways
to do it you speed walk for a minute and
then you know
leisurely walk for 30 seconds or you
know going up and down and that helps
build burn more calories too if you
can't
do other more intense forms of exercise
and i find walking especially valuable
and this is more advice for maybe the
parents but the students as well if you
have a call now that we're working
remotely too and you just walk while you
do it you don't even notice the time
goes by and you all of a sudden you have
like 5 000 steps or 6 000 steps
so it looks like we're getting more and
more questions this is a very popular
topic but we're pretty much at time my
apologies both to you michelle and
everyone else for some of the
difficulties i had on i had on my end uh
but thank you so much for joining i i i
suspect that we'll have more questions
at future times to ask michelle so don't
hesitate to keep those questions coming
uh but i'll just thank everyone for
joining once again this is just a way
for all of us to stay connected to
support each other in what is a trying
time i'll remind everyone again we are
not for profit so your donations are
very much appreciated we're we are
running at a deficit and uh a reminder
for tomorrow's show our guest uh is bill
gates and we're to talk a little bit
about he's really we know him for many
things as a philanthropist as a founder
of microsoft uh but he's really been one
of the people who predicted this
pandemic many years ago he's been giving
speeches about it and he's been at the
center of the the battle so we're going
to talk a lot about epidemiology
tomorrow and where all of this might
lead so thanks everyone for joining
you